die flucht hat viele gesichter und nur
ein ziel und als sie am montagmorgen
endlich die mächtige mauer zum flughafen
überwunden hatten und das rollfeld
belagerten da meinten vielleicht viele
sie hätten es geschafft nur um dann mit
schmerzen zu begreifen dass in den
rettungsfliegern der alliierten kein
platz für sie war
und dann gab es noch ein ganz anderes
gesicht der flucht aus kabul ein
westliches ein ruhigeres aber gewiss
nicht frei von angst jan jessen ein
deutscher reporter berichtet von seiner
rettung das waren ungefähr 20 kilometer
bis zum flughafen und die frage war was
ist da in der stadt jetzt los das wusste
keiner genau also sind wir ein paar
losgefahren so schnell wie möglich
tatsächlich dann auf den straßen viel
viel taliban aktivitäten gesehen taliban
auch polizeiwagen teil über einer
motorrädern taliban auf kreuzungen teils
schwer bewaffnet aber die waren relativ
ds interessiert also habe zwar angeguckt
aber keine anstalten gebracht uns darauf
zu halten am flughafen selbst
katastrophe ganz furchtbare situation
der panische menschen geschreie weinende
frauen schüsse amerikanische winston die
sehr sehr
lautstark dann agiert habe und dahinter
dann die deutschen soldaten den wir dann
unsere pässe gezeigt haben schon winken
durch die menge uns bewegt haben merkt
sich die spannung löst sich wenn man die
ganzen gesicht er sich angeschaut hat
der menschen in dem flugzeug saßen da
bin ich auch viele einheimische dabei
und da war unglaublich viel trauer auch
zu sehen gesichter
etwas mitgenommen hat keiner hat seine
mitarbeiter und freunde leichten herzens
zurück gelassen mit den neuen
machthabern die schwer bewaffnet und mit
undurchsichtigen motiven überall
aufmarschiert sind und nun alles
kontrollieren
wir dienen hier rund um die uhr unserem
volk indem wir leib leben und eigentum
der einwohner dieses distriktes
bewaffnet wir wollen alles tun um die
menschen hier glücklich zu machen und
diejenigen fernzuhalten die unser volk
stören und ausplündern wollten
aber wer der ihre geschichte kennt wird
diesen beteuerungen glauben
auf allen freiflächen der hauptstadt im
schatten am straßenrand die vielen
tausend aus dem ganzen land die es nicht
glauben und die hier gestrandet sind
500.000 binnenflüchtlinge sollen sich in
den vergangenen monaten auf den weg
gemacht haben wenn überhaupt dann nur
notdürftig versorgt und vor den trümmern
ihrer existenz
wir sind mit dem leben davon gekommen
haben aber ich habe weder ersatzkleidung
noch ausweispapiere
ich bin witwe aus mattsee cherry mit
meinen zwei kindern von den taliban
geflohen
wir können moslems einander so etwas
antun in jeder familie gibt es opfer was
ist denn los und was soll ich jetzt tun
und welchen weg nehmen den kürzesten weg
aus kabul vier autostunden nach osten
zur pakistanischen grenze ist seit
sonntag versperrt nur lkw dürfen
inzwischen wieder passieren die taliban
wollen nicht auf zolleinnahmen
verzichten menschen flüchtende gar
kommen nicht durch
und ins nördliche nachbarland usbekistan
kommt nur wer ein gültiges visum
vorweisen kann kaufmann courage war
einer der wenigen glücklichen die
rauskamen seine familie nicht am
grenzübergang sind viele zurückgewiesen
worden hinter mir habe ich mindestens
200 oder 300 menschen gesehen die aber
nicht weiter kraft auch meine verwandten
und meine kinder blieben zurück und
niemand konnte helfen
jeder will sich absichern gegen die
erwartete massenflucht sollten die
taliban erneut ihr schreckens regime
errichten auch der weg nach westen über
iran wird gerade dicht gemacht die
türkei baut eine lange mauer entlang der
grenze und will damit mögliche
eindringlinge wenn nicht abhalten dann
zumindest abschrecken
und doch schaffen es immer wieder
gruppen von afghanen über die berge ins
land diese jungen männer gehören zur
turkmenischen minderheit geflohen schon
lange vor dem fall kabuls
in afghanistan herrscht krieg
was sollen wir machen
unsere dörfer haben die taliban
eingenommen
wir sind seit 22 tagen unterwegs dieser
pakistan nach iran marschiert jetzt
wollen wir weiter nach istanbul
das sind von hier aus noch einmal 1600
kilometer fußmarsch und er führt sie
durch die ostanatolische einöde zunächst
in die großstadt varna am stadtrand
schon jetzt überall gruppen und familien
lagern und einmal mehr daran erinnern
wie viele gesichter die flucht haben
kann
schätzungen zufolge sind bereits einige
hunderttausend afghanen im land manche
schon seit jahren zusätzlich zu den
dreieinhalb millionen syrischen
flüchtlingen ihre anwesenheit und die
aussicht dass nun noch mehr kommen
bringt immer mehr türken gegen sie aus
aber es führt kein weg zurück
auch nicht für goalie ghasemi sie ist 23
mit ihren eltern für sie schon vor elf
jahren nach teheran
eigentlich hatte sie gehofft bald in
ihrer heimatstadt ghazni zurückzukehren
sie wollte dort beim theater arbeiten
aber theater werden die taliban sicher
nicht mehr erlauben
jeden tag in der vergangenen woche sind
mir sehr viele fragen durch den kopf
gegangen wie lange bleiben die taliban
an der macht
werde ich so lange leben bis sich ihr
ende sehen kann wird etwas passieren
wird die internationale gemeinschaft uns
weiterhin ignorieren
innerhalb von nur einer woche sagt sie
hätten sich alle träume für ihre zukunft
zerschlagen und die flucht dauert an und
die angst kommt zurück dass doch alles
umsonst war und die dunkelste zeit von
vorne beginnt